Okay,
so I'm talking today with Dr. Michael Shermer and darker Schermer is among other
things,
the publisher of skeptic magazine,
but more importantly for our purposes today,
he is also the author of this book New Book and were heaven on Earth.
And we're going to talk about this today in some detail.
And so I'm going to turn this over first too dark to Schermer who's going to
tell you some things about himself and then we're going to have a discussion.
He's going to outline this book to them.
We're going to have a discussion about,
well,
why he wrote it and what it contains and what the implications are and all of
that.
So over to you Michael.
Sure,
sure.
Thank you for having me on the show.
Well,
the,
the book is kind of an extension of my previous work.
Most of my books,
when I write them,
they kind of push off from the previous book.
So going all the way back to my first book,
white people believe weird things,
which was about the supernatural into paranormal and,
and all that.
Then then that led to how we believe,
which was white people believe in God.
And then if you don't believe in the supernatural and you don't believe in a
deity,
what about morality?
So I wrote two books on math and science of good and evil and the moral arc last
book.
So then,
you know,
kind of covering all the big subjects.
Uh,
from a skeptical scientific perspective,
the afterlife is obviously a huge one.
And I had really dealt with that too much and my previous books and you know,
now that I'm in my sixties,
I guess you could say I'm cramming for the final
thinking about these big issues.
It's not something I obsess about it.
I'm not terrorized by death like,
like some people that edge they are.
But I think it's a super interesting subject because it's obviously a part of
the human condition.
It's something people do think about.
And apparently we're the only species that can do this.
Although I have a chapter and have designers on animals that grieve clearly.
Quite a few mammals do grieve and they have some sense of loss,
death and grief for fellow group members or family members that die.
There's not clear that they understand that their mortal.
Um,
and then like,
you know,
I covered the possibility that neanderthals were self aware of their mortality
because of grave goods that have been found.
Although that's,
it's hard to,
fossil fossil fossilization of thoughts is difficult to interpret,
but it seems reasonable that they had some sense of that.
But in any case,
um,
uh,
so I,
I deal with the,
you know,
the,
the monotheisms versions of the afterlife,
Heaven and mortality,
a Judaism,
Christianity,
Islam mainly cause you sort of have to,
although mine's a science book and those are sort of low hanging fruit that
atheists have already kind of picked out.
So I don't spend a lot of time on that.
I,
I focused more on scientific attempts to achieve and mortality.
And it's a book of science.
So I actually start with what doesn't seem like a scientific get,
but Deepak Chopra's worldview of sort of western Buddhism that,
um,
that there is the idea birth death.
Um,
afterlives life before life is all kind of meaningless because it's all
consciousness in a detox worldview as he puts it.
Uh,
you know,
consciousness is the ontological primitive free.
You can't get underneath it.
Uh,
you know,
the,
the scientific attempt to explain it by material means will always fail because
that's not where consciousness wise anyway.
So I,
um,
thanks to my wife,
uh,
you know,
actually delved into his world view,
Deepak and I have class for 20 years and I've called his worldview Wu and
pseudoscience and,
and,
you know,
we've been kind of at odds at each other.
So as it changes,
I mean,
he sort of the main you,
I'd say intellectual force.
I don't think it's unreasonable to say the main intellectual force behind the
new age movement or associated with the new age movement.
Is that,
yeah,
certainly one of the most prominent ones.
He's got a huge following.
He goes on Oprah and talks about these things and doctor Oz or whoever,
and he has a lot of following.
So,
um,
my wife and I actually went down to his center that 10% are in Carlsbad,
California.
And spent some time there.
I delved into meditation and Yoga and the tea and the chanting and all that
stuff just to kind of see what it's all about.
And uh,
you know,
I think there's something there in terms of behavioral change that is how it
affects your body and your mind and your thinking.
And I could definitely see something to that.
Um,
but also the difficult part that deep buck and I have had is the same problem
that most scientists have with new age beliefs,
but not just that,
but,
but non western traditions that Deepak calls the eastern wisdom traditions that
it's the language,
the difficulty of language.
We have to use words to communicate.
Um,
and the words you use matter at some level.
You have to be able to be talking on the same level with words.
So when Deepak says,
um,
you know,
the ontological primitive or consciousness is the womb of creation.
You know,
these,
it sounds sort of metaphorical and he means something very specific by that.
If you can't get at that,
then you're wasting your time talking.
So,
um,
tee buck and I had kind of become friends and we,
you know,
we're constantly communicating just to try to see if we can find some ground
where we're talking on the same plane.
And so I think I've,
uh,
learned a lot from him in that,
in that sense.
And so my chapters devoted to him on that and the general eastern wisdom
traditions,
you know that when you die,
cause I always ask them what,
where do you go?
And he said,
at least it's this the wrong question.
I mean you just returned to where you were before.
You know,
cause when people ask me,
well what do you think happens after you die?
My standard kind of quip is the same thing.
You go to the same place you worked before you were born.
I'll say,
what are you talking about?
I wasn't anywhere before I was born.
Right?
And you'll be nowhere after you die.
But for depo time and consciousness kinda overrides the concept of time at the
beginning and an end by your consciousness just returns to where it was and that
the physical body and brain,
just a temporary instantiation of consciousness into physical being.
But it just goes back to some other place.
And then there's like a figure.
We don't have the words to even conceive of what that means.
Uh,
that is the western language and the way scientists talk that can't really
capture what he's talking about it in that sense.
And so that's why I think we kind of hit a,
an epistemological wall there where you have to actually get into introspection,
meditation,
and the deeper parts of that tradition that I've never been able to really get
into personally.
So I can't say I understand it,
although I kind of see where he's coming from in that regard.